ich sagte schon das problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig statt haben wir haben
zu viel staat werden einen wolf hat
start der außer rand und band geraten
ist der familien und alleinstehende und
alleinerziehende mütter das inzwischen
auch einen beruf versorgt wir kamen ein
klima paket die leute kriegen zuschüsse
zu den heizungskosten jetzt gibt es
sogar habe ich neulich gehört ein tank
rabatt der sich aber nicht dahin
auswirkt dass die preise sinken können
so dass irgendwelche lieferanten
zwischendurch mehr verdienen das ist zu
viel staat darum das beste beispiel für
die konfusion die verwirrung für diesen
absurden idealismus der staatsbehörden
ist das 9 euro ticket das neurotiker das
wissen dass es der reine zynismus wenn
ich darauf angewiesen wäre würde ich
nicht wirklich massiv empören und mit
diesem ticket versuchen irgendwo nach
sambia zu fahren oder zu fliegen nur um
diesem milieu zu entkommen 9 euro wie
kommt man auf 9 warum nicht zehn euro
warum nicht 7 euro 50 wie viele
fachleute haben wochenlang da
zusammengesessen und sich dieses ding
ausgedacht und das ergebnis sehen wir es
findet kein umstieg von der strasse auf
die bahn statt ich habe die bilder über
pfingsten sehr genossen und hat mir sehr
gut gefallen wo die leute im zug stehen
und zwar so hin zu stehen kein abstand
keine masken keine hygienemaßnahmen
offenbar kommt es in solchen situationen
ich darauf an und es mit den leuten den
eindruck vermittelt der staat das was
sie wollen der staat macht was für sie
erscheint ihnen was gibt ihnen die
möglichkeit von berg das garten nach
kiel für neun euro zu fahren dauert zwei
drei tage mit den regionalzügen aber
immerhin und das ist das ist sozusagen
die ursünde die überversorgung die
einmischung des staates in alles und bei
diesem neuen euro es ist wirklich ein
gigantischer blöcke seien gross
versuchung zu sehen wie weit man die
leute in die irre führen kann verarschen
kann sie kriegen in die eine tasche das
neurotiker dreien gestreckt und aus der
anderen tasche kriegen sie ihr geld
wieder entzogen alsfeld in einem haben
sie leider vollkommen recht es fehlt
jedes bewusstsein für wirtschaftliche
zusammenhänge dass auch gymnasien heute
wirtschaft kein pflichtfach ist auch so
dass die kinder nicht wissen wie geld
funktioniert oder wie die wertschöpfung
gerade beim neuen euro ticket helfen
nein es würde uns nicht helfen weil es
zu spät für solche maßnahmen aber so
heißt wie das finanziert aber es wird
schon mal nicht schlecht wenn die leute
begreifen würden dass sie ein neurotiker
selber finanzieren unter anderem auch
darüber dass das eine achtprozentige
inflation gibt von der die leute
enteignet werden so aber das gerät in
den hintergrund weil das ständigen wir
hilfen sub zuschüsse subventionen gibt
übrigens gibt das ganze berufsstände die
davon leben leute zu beraten wie sie und
subventionen herankommen das ist auch
ein absolutes wohlfahrtsstaat glauben
sie denn 109 euro ticket sich gegangen
habe ich nicht nein nein sie machen sie
auch nicht haltbares offenheit für mich
ist das der hammer
aber ich stelle mir vor in einem
zurückbilden
überzeugenden wahl zu stehen und und
nähe also dass das war der horror für
mich jetzt und meine beine ich hatte
heute besuch von einer dame die immer
mit der bahn versuchte es ist nicht mehr
auszuhalten das ist nicht es ist so voll
du kannst das nicht aus ist eine
katastrophe also ich kann das nicht
bestätigen eaton gestern erst der klasse
von warschau nach berlin gefahren das
war okay gut dass da zählt aber nicht
das neue hotel in dem ich den schalter
oder runter gehen sie denn mit bei herr
bruder
ja ich mein herr bruder beschreibt die
situation ziemlich zu treffen und wir
als bürger haben natürlich da auch eine
gehörige mitschuld also ich hab das ja
sehr intensiv verfolgt auch in den
letzten jahrzehnten dass die politiker
die neue wohltaten aufrufen dass die
gewählt werden das aber
diejenigen die irgendwie versuchen etwas
zu streichen dann auch mit hinweise da
vollkommen richtig dass das ja aus dem
steuergeld kommt dass das ja letztlich
das geld ist der der bürger was da
ausgegeben wird dass das aber überhaupt
nicht verfängt und dass diejenigen
politiker so gnadenlos abgestraft werden
dass im prinzip einpacken können das
lernt jeder politiker sehr sehr schnell
und deswegen habe ich da auch wenig
hoffnung dass sich das schnell etwas
grundlegend ändert ich rauche nicht frau
suding die fdp dazu gehören sie jetzt
nicht mehr aber die fdp hat ja den tank
rabatt jetzt auch gemacht der nähe stark
scheint überall angekommen zu beim gast
beim neuen euro ticket und eigentlich
ist es ja der steuerzahler der das alles
ermöglicht ja natürlich das ist ja genau
das was wo wir ein bewusstsein
entwickeln müssten dass das was man den
menschen aus der tasche zieht aus der
einen tasche
verwurstet wird in einen staatsapparat
und dann zugeteilt wie ist wiederum
macht die fdp dass sie macht es nicht
alleine sie machen alle politiker machen
der irgendwie mittag an und meine partei
sich auch nicht ausnehmen das ist
sicherlich auch ganz große versuchung da
ja das wohlwollen sich des bürgers zu
erkaufen weil das ist auch einer der
gründe warum sie die politische bühne
verlassen haben nein das hatte bei mir
ganz persönliche gründe ich wollte
einfach mein leben zurück das hat
weniger was mit programmatik zu tun wo
ich unzufrieden war das da hättest ja
noch genug gegeben wo ich aber wir
wollen alle unser leben zurück weil sie
zurück
zurückgeben das war eine
sehr spitz ausgedrückt die menschen
haben ihr leben alle noch nicht so
zurück nachdem lockt und wir haben lange
noch nicht zurück und das meine ich
damit wir wollen unsere leben zurück ich
habe mein leben zurück aber die meisten
haben erleben nicht zurück die meistens
in völlig lost die wissen überhaupt gar
nicht sofort wohin gesetzt und wo haben
sie denn schon apathisch ernst letztlich
große geschenke vom staat tank rabatt ja
also große geschenke sind mir suspekt da
war ja auch man kriegt nichts geschenkt
man kriegt nichts geschenkt es kommt mir
meine rechnung ist ein bisschen
professor seligmann der begründer der
positiven psychologie und das ist das
was wir gemacht haben mit der
gesellschaft man wir haben in die
verantwortung abkommen wenn ich heute
sehe der titel vom stern ja können wir
uns die reichen noch leisten auf lindner
abgebildet war da weiß ich weiß ja
politiker werden immer gerne dafür
genommen und ich habe nicht
das haben neben darauf gemacht aber dass
das ist genau das ist genau der punkt
also wir müssen den menschen immer mehr
verantwortung geben und auch sagen dass
sie eben selbst für ihre ausbildung
verantworte sind selbst weiterbildung
verantwortlich sind und das ist genau
das was wir heute an möglichkeiten haben
auch durch die digitalisierung aber das
hat er wohl das ist richtig schön gesagt
der staat richtet ja irgendwie ich kenne
menschen die kommen einfach durch und
dann haben wir noch eins geschaffen wir
haben alle 2 gesellschaft geschaffen das
war wie in der pandemie die dämpfen die
die nicht impfen und so haben wir
geschaffen die die reichen die die
arbeitsplätze schaffen sind die bösen
ausbeuter da gibt es sicherlich schwarze
schafe wie überall aber es gibt auch
viele die arbeitsplätze schaffen die
halt eben einen großen beitrag leisten
wenn man mal sieht jetzt wird gefordert
neueste idee 57 prozent
spitzensteuersatz
naja wenn ich mir nochmal die angucken
dich eben beschrieben habe das sind 0,1
prozent plus eben ein prozent also sagen
wir das
wirklich so wer soll das dann irgendwann
noch finanzieren und das muss auch mal
klar sein wo sehen sie heute noch ein
unternehmer der auch mal in die politik
geht der sagt ich setz mich mit denen
auseinander weil die so weltfremd sind
und vom normalen arbeiter leben genau
sie vom unternehmerleben weg sind da
kommen menschen heute zum
bewerbungsgespräch mit 24 noch mal eine
kleine anekdote fahren wollen wenn ich
in die politik gehen weil ich möchte
auch nicht mit zu vielen lehrern darum
1821 lehrer dabei bei 7 65 abgeordneten
die zweithöchste zahl nach china
brauchen wir das ich bin eher dafür dass
von expertenrunde kriegen wenn wir das
kriegen können dann bin ich dabei ich
habe frau merkel angeschrieben sie hatte
man eine menge wir haben noch nichts tun
ist ja auch das stimmt nicht ich habe
frau merkel machen schrieben sie hatte
eine ausschreibung suchte zwei leute
zwei psychologen mit doktortitel die
helfen der regierung ein neues gesicht
zu gehen ich hab sie angeschrieben dass
ich weder studiert habe noch ein
doktortitel aber ich wusste wie es geht
und ich gebe auch für die erste beratung
ohne berechnung was bekam ich zurück ein
standardschreiben schön dass sie frau
merkel und der partei weiter wohl bisher
ja ein bisschen selbstüberschätzung
direkt frau merkel beraten zu wollen ich
hatte gute idee und werde ich auch heute
noch aber das problem ist auch wenn sie
wenn sie heute leute suchen wenn ich
junge menschen suchen
kreative leute um mich zu unterstützen
im team das in allen nicht mehr
belastbar das sind alle nicht mehr
belastbar sind alle haben schon ein
burnout wenn sie ankommen mit mein tempo
vor neun jahren mit meinem team bekommen
die gar nicht mit also da sind die
gleich nach drei tagen sind die dann
hören die auch schon wieder auf und und
und ja er hat eine warum ist es so dass
der schneepflug